my guest tonight is of course a very
talented comedian whose new show the
cabin
with bert kreischer is streaming now on
netflix you can also see him live
on his hot summer nights tour which will
be making a stop
at the rose bowl on wednesday october
28th and this man gives a good show
please welcome
bert kreischer bert how are you i'm
doing fantastic
i named it the hot summer nights tour
and the last show i did was in chicago
in 28 degree weather with snow flurries
shirtless
that's right you you obviously like to
show off your body
um as one should if they're in your
shape and you
so was could you see steam rising off
your body
in the 28 degree weather oh no i had six
i i think it was six or nine heaters on
stage with me
like tubes blowing hot air space heaters
like i was out eating at a at an app
at outdoors applebee's it was aggressive
i looked like such a wimp
it was i was horrible but it was nice i
kept thinking wim hof you don't get sick
whim off does it so i just embraced my
my breathing
yeah that's what you have to do i think
we're all doing the best we can during
trying times you may have heard uh we
came into
the theater we're in i know you've
performed in this theater largo a
million times
we showed up yesterday our equipment got
ripped off
um we're living in a post-apocalyptic
nightmare all of us but we're doing the
best we can
who breaks into largo the sweetest human
beings in the world work there
own that place attend that venue that is
like that's like ripping off a nun
[Laughter]
and also there was a nun staying here
they beat her with a club
she tried to sleep you went to if you
went to catholic grade school that
might be i i can understand trust me i
had my catholic education
and that uh well let's just say this the
ev it's even the score
uh let's all say uh i want to talk about
these shows you're doing you're doing
these drive-in shows
what's it like i mean you are out there
in the middle of a pandemic
but you have found a way to bring the
christ your magic to the people and i
applaud you for that
how's it going does it feel pretty kovid
safe
oh it's very coveted safe we've done now
four tours across this country
and uh yeah the first one we didn't know
if it was gonna work which is the
dumbest
insight now because my fans love the
tailgate like my fans
love to tailgate i mean people show up
they have smokers they have filled the
bed of their trucks with water
they have couch setups they have
inflatable mattresses
it is i mean it is it's almost like when
i was like i wonder if they show up
that's like jimmy buffett going i hope
my fans like margaritas like it is
they are through the roof and the shows
are amazing i love them i'm having so
much fun
and it's offering people and this is
what i like is offering people
a chance of normalcy and to stay as safe
as they want
they can get out of the car and be
around their car if they want they can
stay in their car they don't have to get
out of their car
and i'm one of those people like i would
definitely i would probably tailgate a
little bit the
drunker i got the more adventurous i got
but it's been absolutely amazing i wish
more comics had the opportunity to do it
i think a lot of people
heard uh heard heard that oh they'd be
honking and
stuff they only hunk at the end of the
show for a standing ovation conan it is
the most amazing standing ovation you've
ever got
they flick their high beams hit their
horns you feel like you're getting
abducted by aliens it is the
greatest i would like it if i did that
and i told a joke that was so good that
everyone's airbag went off
that would make me happy
heads were blown back like their noses
were broken by the impact of my comedy
that's what i want
this sounds like a lot of fun i also
want to bring up you have an interesting
birthday your birthday is november 3rd
now this year obviously that this year
november 3rd is going to be a
fraught day for a lot of people
regardless of your political orientation
it's going to be a tense
day filled with uh maybe anger
anxiety and it's your birthday
you know what are you what are you going
to do this november 3rd are you still
going to try and have a conventional
birthday
no there's no way anyone's going to be
at my party not looking at the tv going
see this is what's wrong with our
country this isn't and i'm like hey
happy birthday no that's not going to
happen
i'm thinking about i'm thinking about
getting a cabin in the woods and taking
my girls out there so that when la's
done burning
we can come in and claim our balls
you know la can burn and it doesn't have
to be political it could just be
someone someone dropped a cigarette like
60 miles from here
you know so uh yeah don't worry i mean
but i i
i i have sympathy for you that your
birthday is on november 3rd
i'm curious do you have a memory of a
birthday in your life that was a life
changer like a day that just stands out
to you
as that was the birthday that was really
important to me
yeah yeah it's not a good one but yeah
my 26th birthday
i just moved to new york i was saying i
was getting into stand-up i really
wasn't doing anything i was just
partying
and november 2nd we got really lit
because you party
up till midnight on your bro you know
that's how i used to do it
you say one does that uh i don't do that
but that's what you do
okay all right yeah and so i
i woke up really hung over to my phone
ringing and it was my dad
and i was on the couch like i was on i
didn't even make it to my loft bed in
new york i'm on the couch and i go you
know what
i'm just gonna answer the phone and let
him say happy birthday to me real quick
and then i'm gonna go back to bed i'm
hungover
so i just grabbed the phone like hey
what's up i need just cause
you are a human piece of garbage
like oh what he was like he was like
he goes i just perjured myself i
just pursued myself i was in court and
the judge said
hey how's your son doing and i said
great i lied
because i couldn't say your honor my son
is no humility he's a garbage he says
he's gonna do something
and he doesn't do it and i go i go dad
it's my birthday he goes i know what day
it is
and he called you he called you human
garbage
on your birthday the first and he broke
me down
so bad you have no humility i messed you
up you're just gonna be a party boy
you're the number one party animal keep
partying party boy i'll pay for it you
don't have to do anything you'll never
achieve anything in life you say you
want to be a comic you won't be a comic
and then i i was like hey i how do i fix
this because you can't fix it
you can't you can't you don't have the
capability i messed up as a man
as a father i messed you up so just
don't worry about it
go party your balls off tonight i was
like hold on i said i need to fix this
and he goes if you want to fix this
you go to that comedy club that you've
been hanging out at drinking beers
and you tell them you'll do anything
you'll mop up you'll that's how it works
he goes no that's not how it works for
you
because you've been given everything in
your life because let me tell you
something some young black kid in harlem
is doing that today and he will succeed
because he has
he has what it takes to get to the next
level you don't have it i go okay i'll
do it so i go that night i told my mom
tell my dad
i can't do tonight i have a party and he
goes you don't deserve a party
what are you partying for and so
i went i didn't go out that night i went
to the comedy club i
talked to the guy louis schaefer i said
hey um i want to be a comic i'll do
anything he told me to move back to
florida and i was like
okay i'll opt in whatever so i go back i
call my dad the next morning
he said how'd it go i said he told me to
move back florida he was perfect
he goes you go to that club again
tonight pretend you've never had that
conversation
and start from zero say hey my name's
bert chrysler i'd like to be a comedian
and when he
shoots you down again you show up the
next night you show up you show up
persistent
and humble and that is how you leave
your life and i went okay
it sounded crazy to me and i did it the
next night and louis ever goes i thought
i told you move back to florida and i
said listen
yesterday was my dad my birthday my dad
called me a human visa garbage told me i
wasn't worth anything
i'm going to be doing this until my dad
says i have to stop so i'm going to be
here every single night he goes listen
if you want to work the door you can
work the door if you bring in 25 people
i'll put you on the end of the night
and i was like for real and he was like
yeah i called my dad
i was so excited i go work he goes of
course it worked
he goes you approach stuff with humility
and i'm telling you conan six months
later
will smith discovered me i started doing
television and if it wasn't
for that 26th birthday break off my dad
gave me
it hurts so bad yeah i wouldn't be
talking to you right now
you know i feel like i've done a pretty
good job in my career my dad calls me
every birthday and says you're a human
piece of garbage
and then i'm like what and he goes like
wait oh i'm sorry and he's like i
thought i was talking to one of your
brothers
i apologize hey how's your um you've
talked on my show
about your daughter uh uh georgia before
is what is she is she 15 16
how old is she just turned 16 the conan
just just turned 16. okay and and how's
that going because she sounds like a
character she sounds uh you you have
some good
you have some good stories about her uh
she got into an accident
yesterday oh no i'm sorry can't laurel
canada chandler
good old georgia
she's driving yeah i knew i knew she i
love her i love
my kids i trashed them a lot but this
[ __ ] was not ready to drive
literally we were driving through a
neighborhood one time and she's
her her and i look i was in the back
ayla sees the sign says deaf child and
jordan goes and isla goes well that's
racist i was like
huh how's that right it's not racist at
all that's what's wrong with these kids
it's not
i go isla they put that sign that
georgia goes dad i'll take this one
she goes isla they put that sign up so
that we know when we're in this
neighborhood
we should lower our radios so we don't
rub it in that we can hear
like that's actually not at all why they
put that sign up there
you know there's a child that may not
hear your car coming so you need to pay
extra attention and she goes
well it sounds like they're making me do
all the work
i can't believe she's out driving uh it
frightens me and i'm gonna look
three ways before i cross any street now
if i know i if i know she's in town
well let's talk about you uh this is a
cool idea
the cabin with bert kreischer i i was
watching this show and it's a very
good idea because the top of the show
you're very honest
it explains very quickly that you live a
hard you live hard
you live hard you party hard you work
hard you
you like your food you like your drink
you push it and you push it and you push
it
and you finally decided i'm going to
take a break and i'm going to go into a
cabin
and i'm going to try and relax and
is that that's the premise of the show
but initially you were just going to go
to a cabin
and relax and you turned it into a
television show
i do that with everything i did that
with this tour i was like i was like hey
i'm doing a tour in the pandemic i'm
bringing the camera crew
netflix you want it and they're like huh
like i can't help it i just
i think of everything as like wasting
time if i'm not making something
and i like making stuff and so i was i
just the first person i called was to
sagura
and i was like hey you want to come up
maybe we'll shoot something he was like
yeah
and so he came up and he called joey and
then they got an ounce of weed and
the next you know we're like ah let's
call miss pat and then
joel mchale and then dion and and
anthony anderson and it was and donna
rollins
bobby lee the list of guys people that i
brought up there to hang out with me
is my is those are the funniest human
beings on the planet in my opinion
and that's why people are liking the
show is that you were just letting
hilarious people be hilarious no
boundaries
no nothing and uh and netflix is their
guidance was beautiful
and we're like it was perfect it was a
lot of fun
well you know i was uh i'm i'm good
friends with dionne cole
and i've known him for a long time and
he's such a hilarious guy
and i just i'm thinking i love just the
concept of dion
out in the woods in a cabin because that
doesn't seem like dion's thing did he
have a good time
it is not dion's thing dion
like the first thing the first thing we
did that day was because i've always
wanted to
everything i did out there is stuff i
want to do like i want i'm always
looking for a quick fix
right like we got chickens in our houses
and i was like i want a beehive i think
a beehive would be cool so we went
to see if we could collect honey from
beehive and dion's like i don't like
bees
and i was like you grew up in chicago
like how can a bee
scare you and he's like i don't like
bees and then he's like
we're getting robbed he goes i don't
like getting rough the only thing he
really took to
was spitting on me like he i got stung
by a bee and we were smoking cigars
and they were like you need tobacco spit
and before i could get it out of my
mouth he's spitting on me and i'm like
hey dion i think you got it he could not
stop spinning on me i was like no he was
this was
this was to help the bee sting he had
totally
he was spinning it on you yeah but he
just it was the way he was doing it was
so
just like just just like
i mean he he had so much fun spitting on
me he's like i've never gotten a spit on
a white guy before
this is great
i was like if i ever get in trouble with
black twitter i'm using that clip and
going hey guys we're even
yeah yeah yeah no it feels right it
feels like this is good this is a good
catharsis
for you know this is very good i'm glad
that dion got to spit on you
you regularly ask questions on your
podcast is that something you might you
have any questions that you might want
to ask me
yes i do this all the time i do it with
bill burb i have two podcasts one two
bears one came with tom sagura and then
bill burt
with bill burr and burr is always good
to ask questions like what would you
rather uh
hit a hole-in-one or hit a walk-off home
run oh walk-off home run
right yes that's obvious to me
hole-in-one would just feel like
just pure chance walk-off home run feels
more like skill
and i would love just dropping the bat
and being a total douche about it
do you know what i mean i would love
just dropping the bat and putting and
really taking my time going around the
bases
and to the point where the pitcher would
maybe charge me
come at me i would totally play it up i
would love a walk-off home run
all right what about dunk or speak
french
uh man that's a good one i'm gonna go
with speak french
or can i have speak french as i dunk but
only as i'm dunking
i can speak french
in that moment when i'm dunking i'm
fluent in french
so when i go up and i dunk i
just start talking about descartes and
moliere
and everyone around me under the
basket's just like what the
what is this this is incredible and then
when i'm when i come back down again
i and i've dunked the basketball i no
longer speak french
okay here's here's my favorite one and
it's gonna take a little thought okay
so i'll answer first but i'll put it up
to you this is me and bill's favorite
one
you get to drive a brand new car you can
time travel to any time period and drive
the car of your dreams right when it was
released and what music would you listen
to driving that car around
now i would go to like 68
69 and i would get a cadillac
convertible
big big long one and i would listen to
the rolling stones okay i would time
travel to 1923
but i'd be driving a car from 1925.
okay it's just a two-year difference
it's just a model and and it's slightly
different and i would be
playing a song that wasn't it's like a
rudy valley song
that hasn't come out yet but it's only
two years off
so i've gone to all the trouble to time
travel and have the machine i want but
instead of going back
to uh 1620 and being worshipped as a god
for having this machine i'm showing up
and people are like
say that looks like a 1918 you know 1920
model t and i'll say
no it's not chum it's a 1922
model d and then they'll say is that
rudy valley singing and i'd say yes
but this won't be released for four
months
button up when the wind blows free
take good care of yourself you belong to
me
i don't know i love wasting people's
time and that would be a huge waste
a huge waste of time travel a huge waste
of time
travel oh that's that's a perfect answer
well you know it's what i do it's a it's
a terrible waste
of the whole concept but that's what i
want to do
so where are you right now before i sign
off where are you i'm in sedona
i'm coming into la tonight oh cool all
right and
and you're doing a show with the rose
bowl yeah skirt the rose bowl bow to a
stand up
and uh wednesday night i can't wait all
right i got a lot to plug here because
you're a busy man the cabin with bert
kreischer
is uh now streaming globally on netflix
and that shows a lot of fun
and you can find dates uh for bert's
hot summer nights tour at
bertbertbert.com what happened did
someone else take
bert burt no someone had
by the way i've got bert bert also i've
also got diet bird i've got
i've got everything around it some guy
had bert it was his dog
yeah nice nice yeah uh okay
bertbertbert.com bert kreischer always
really fun uh talking to you and i'm so
happy you're out there
bringing joy because people need it
right now they really do
oh i appreciate it thank you for having
me on conan i love you i love blue
hairstyle tell the people at largo i
said i'm so sorry
[Laughter]
they didn't it wasn't that bad it wasn't
that bad and you know what it's
like an inside job conan no i really i
really
i really believe like andy richter
yesterday was way too
like this is terrible this is terrible
and i noticed
i noticed he was wearing like a new
jacket i'm like
[Laughter]
you know by the way i've got a picture
on my uh
the other way apple just randomly sends
you photos from
your collection of photos just every day
you just get a random
the other day i'm doing something and
i'm about to bite into like a croissant
and this picture slides up and it's you
and me doing a selfie
at comic con yeah remember that and like
your fake
your it's your face and my face mashed
up together
and i was like yeah i love that apple
does that it goes hey
did you forget your dog died and you're
like oh yeah
remember her she's dead hey
these are some good times all right bert
kreischer thank you sir